Intrugo's new election reform Bill
there is a curious change in the election date for 2025,
delaying it by just a single week.
This
proposed change has raised speculation that this move might seek to
ensure Liberal MPs
reach the minimum service period for pension eligibility
for potentially losing power.
Under the current laws,
federal elections are scheduled for the third Monday of October,
not exceeding four years after the previous election.
This means the next election should be set for Monday,
October 18th, 2025 at the absolute latest.
However, this is seemingly inconvenient for the Liberal MPs,
whose pensions wouldn't kick in until three days later,
on October 21st, 2025.
The proposed reforms Intrudeau's newly tabled Bill C65,
includes a provision to hold the election on Monday,
October 27th, 2025,
allowing enough time to ensure that
taxpayers will fund the retirement of bureaucrats
who are actively running the country into the ground.